die afb schleicht sich weiter frauke
petry will nicht mehr spitzenkandidatin
werden
ja wir kleinen häusler
das war die meldung vor dem parteitag
morgen in köln sprechendes offen aus
deutschland hat wirklich die
schlechteste rechte europa wirklich es
ist doch so wenn man dabei fast immer
weltmarktführer in sachen faschismus ist
sinnlos mit uns und wer glaubt denn
bitte wer glaubt denn das frauke petry
ernsthaft gegen rechts ist überhaupt ein
sehr seltsames video das die frau da
gepostet hat meine damen und herren
wissen sie noch jeder für sich
warum sagt 2013 in die sed eingetreten
sind
nein ich bin auch gar nicht in die spd
eingetreten und etwas später der euro
ist gescheitert können dass kurs
korrigieren das so jetzt stimmt danke
petri selber hat doch die parteien nach
rechts außen geführt sie wollte das wort
völkisch wieder positiv besetzen und
jetzt waren die park & co die
zerstrittenen lager sind alle recht
sie mögen sich einfach menschlich nicht
und manche wollen früher reagieren als
andere
petri zum beispiel fordert dass wir uns
ab jetzt konsequent auf die übernahme
von regierungsverantwortung ein senior
partner in der darauf folgenden
legislatur ab 2021 vorbereiten ansatz
verstanden
sie denkt dass sie in vier jahren
kanzlerin ist steile these dachte man
soll nicht trinken während der
schwangerschaft naja können keine ab
[Applaus]